you know there's a lot of things in life
we can measure we can measure what kind
of return your mutual fund made we can
measure how tall you are
we can measure what you weigh we can
measure your closing percentage and sale
but how do you measure mental and
emotional toughness
we're going to talk about that today
[Music]
so i have several points to go through
with you but let's start off with the
first one you ever hear the saying
before
never judge a book by its cover well
never judge
toughness by its cover let me give you a
personal story with my wife
so my wife and i are in l.a okay we're
about to have our first baby we hire a
doula doula comes in
at our house asks all these questions
from my wife
how do you want to have your baby you
know you want to do c-section how do you
want to do she says
i want to have a natural baby she says
yeah natural birth i get it you know a
lot of people
you know want to do that but really what
if it doesn't go the way you want it and
what
she says i want to have a natural birth
says okay well what if you know what if
you're like you know cause
she says no i want to have now and i'm
sitting there thinking to myself what
does natural really mean
she says do you want pitocin no do you
want epidural
no do you want anything to give in to
you no i want to do it all natural
you want to do it all natural i wanna do
it all natural in my mind i'm sitting as
the man right and i'm saying
i don't know about me if i had the
choice man we're scheduling something at
six o'clock c-section let's get
you know do you know what you're
thinking you're like okay boom we're
getting
you look at my wife quiet to herself
when it came down to that northridge
hospital
and she was going through it guess what
she did natural on the first one
natural on the second one natural on the
third one if you look at my wife
she doesn't say much she's quiet to
herself you cannot judge
toughness by what somebody looks like
never judge toughness by its cover
pain tolerance is one of the biggest
factors of someone who can handle
pressure
because the whole idea of pressure is
there's pain
that pain could be embarrassment that
pain could be i don't know if i can
handle this
that pain could be a lot of different
things you know ralph waldo emerson once
said
the difference between a hero and an
average person is that the hero goes
five minutes longer meaning the hero can
handle the pain
five minutes longer than the other
person well my wife had the baby
she said when the pain hit me and i was
like there's no way i can feel it's like
a train she tells me the story
i don't know what it means she says i
just had to hang in there for a few
minutes longer
and then it was over with that's pretty
much what this means right so that's one
method
of how to measure someone's toughness
here's the second one
preparation david blaine who is
what he called david blaine i don't know
if you call him a magician you call him
a lot of different things
he's a performer david blaine decides to
play the game
of let me see how long i can hold my
breath underwater right
and one day he wants to go on the oprah
winfrey show
and on the oprah winfrey show he wants
to uh break the record the world record
right
and he goes 17 minutes and four seconds
holding his breath
underwater what's the longest you've
ever held your breath underwater
actually think about it and comment
below
what's the longest you've ever held your
breath underwater i think about it
myself
whenever i'm by a pool i tell guys hey
let's who can hold their breath on the
water
one guy goes in 30 seconds 45 seconds a
minute i remember we're in
cancun and one of our guys ricardo lopez
nieves held his breath underwater
minute 30 seconds and his son did it for
a minute 20 seconds no that's crazy
crystal garcia did it for minutes six
seconds we were blown away by this
how can you do this right well he goes
and he prepares for it because he goes
to the doctor and says when i'm under
water i want to know my body
okay at what point does my lung collapse
at what point does my brain collapse
because it needs oxygen
he does research to prepare for the pain
that's going to come
and then he goes and does it publicly he
goes under water for 17 minutes and four
seconds
that is a method of preparation to know
how to handle
pressure the reason why i say handling
pressure and
having mental toughness with preparation
is because
sometimes if you're going to be doing
something and you just kind of put
yourself out there say you're playing
sports say you're doing business they're
about to give a speech
i remember one time i'm about to give a
speech
in front of 150 executives and i really
wanted to make
a a statement i wanted people to leave
and say that guy gave the best message
out of everybody
the night before one of the executives
in atlanta says hey let's go to the
local joint you know
strip joint all this other stuff i
didn't go with him this is all for
50 people go i said i'm good guys i
stayed behind i
roll played my speech till 3 30 in the
morning
i was giving it in the morning 10 am i
was the one that was speaking
i gave my talk by the end of the day
everybody was saying who was the best
talk patrick they
gave the best talk but when i got up in
front of these 150 executives that i
wanted to make a statement at 25 years
old that i'm here to play
everybody walked away saying holy moly
what happened i was not
nervous because i did it so many times
the night before
in my hyatt hotel in duluth georgia
to go and present this to everybody
preparation
has a lot to do with you knowing how to
measure toughness here's the next one
for you
chadwick boseman just died okay here's a
man that did
jackie robinson he did black panther
the guy's a great speaker he had a story
one time when he was getting
a job and he says i don't i want to i
don't want to do regular roles
regular roles for african-american
stories i don't want to do that i want
to get people to be thinking in a
different way
typically when they do a role you know
the the role
kid wasn't raised without a father
figure mom was a heroin addict he's
saying to this to the producer that i'm
not willing to take this role
and then he doesn't get the job you know
and he says man but i needed the money
maybe i should have done something else
right and then later on he ends up doing
two of the biggest movies
and he loses weight and they say oh he's
preparing for a movie
god colon cancer none of us knew about
it let me get this straight he's had
colon cancer for four years
and the world doesn't know about it
aren't we living in a time where you're
supposed to expose
all your problems at any given moment
aren't all these huffington post experts
telling people
publicize your pain and share it with
the world
well chadwick boseman says no it's none
of your business is my
problem it's my pain never use it as an
excuse to not make those movies
i watch both of them you never made that
as an excuse to make black panther and
to make
jackie rob and a bunch of other things
this guy did
never showed hurt one way you measure
toughness
is just look how much people show hurt
just look the other day i was doing some
interview with somebody and the guy was
asking me questions said what do i need
to do to get a promotion this was just
last week i said you know
i don't know if you are going to be here
long term with us he says why not
i said because every time i look at your
face it looks like the end of the world
is here
you just don't look happy and your
attitude doesn't look good
and you've been like this for a while
and we've asked you why
and you seem like you know there's no
problems but you're always showing
everything on your face why would
somebody want to be around somebody like
that for too long
and you want a promotion attitude goes a
long way
so again going back to this guy here
chadwick boseman
rest in peace passes away four years has
colon cancer no one knows about it
he goes to the doctor that means that
this doesn't mean he's not taking care
of his body
he's going to the doctor but he doesn't
advertise his pain
sometimes it's just good not to
advertise your pain sometimes it's good
to not just tell the whole world what
you're going through
i'm not telling you don't talk about it
with a group of people i'm not telling
you have some private conversations with
certain people
i do believe in the ability to have some
kind of a form of a release
but the way people are doing it right
now posting everything on instagram all
this other stuff
what's the point behind it you need
attention is that what you need it's not
necessarily mental toughness
mental toughness people are not looking
for attention mental toughness people
are trying to get results a big
difference let me continue
next one you know life is going to test
you
every freaking day let me explain to you
it's a very weird thing so
you could have one week the best week of
your life next week something dramatic
happens i don't know why life works this
way
it just does you can have one week
everything goes bad next week everything
goes good and great
that's how life is you're getting tested
so sometimes
when you're in it and you're going
through challenging times here's what
you think
you think in the moment you are the only
person that's going through it
it's a problem by the way you when i was
going through when i was in that 49
thousand dollars and
sat down with my dad i said i'm in debt
49 000
life is tough i want you to bail me on
he says i'm gonna give you the best
lesson of your life i said what's that
he says i'm not paying off your debt
you got to figure out a way to pay it
off i said what kind of a debt are you
i'm not paying off your debt i'll help
you here and there but i'm not paying
off your forty nine thousand dollars a
debt you're gonna figure out a way to
pay it off
and i hope you don't file bankruptcy
because at that point all my friends
were following bankruptcy
with the credit cards and it's just kind
of like let me have a fresh start
because you're young
you know what he did to me i couldn't
stand what he did to me but i was being
tested at that time with my debt
i was being tested at that time with my
girlfriend girl i loved that didn't work
out
i was being tested at that time with my
family i was being tested at that time
with
in every possible way and i went and
parked outside of the army recruiting
station
about to get out of my mitsubishi
eclipse 1990
read i was about to get out and get back
in the military
now what if in 1999 2000
i got back in the military what if in
one i just went back to the military and
said this is too hard
i'm just gonna go back in the army what
if i did that what would i be today you
wouldn't know who i am today if i would
have gone back in the military
but in that moment i was being tested
you're gonna be tested in your marriage
while you're running a career you're
going to be tested with your family with
somebody passing away
while you're chasing your dreams arnold
was going to win mr universe
the day before a few days before his
father dies he tells his mom i can't
make you to the funeral because my
dad if he's watching over me he wants me
to pursue my dreams i'm going to win mr
universe
he goes from mr universe and the rest is
history this doesn't mean he doesn't
love his dad
this means he's got a spiritual
relationship with his dad to say i don't
know what i do in this moment here
he goes he wins wieder figures him out
becomes mr olympia
you know governor all these other things
that he does
in those moments of the decisions we
make
when we're getting tested and you feel
like you're by yourself that's
those are moments where you're measuring
your toughness those are moments where
you're being tested constantly
again there's not a method to say you're
tough you're 71 tough we can't do that
the only way we can measure toughness at
the end of the day is with the results
that you end up getting it's really how
you end up measuring toughness by the
results that you end up
getting let me continue here's another
one you ever hear people calling someone
soft
oh he's soft oh she's so soft what is
i'm asking you what is soft you've heard
that before
oh he's soft he's a soft player he's
soft
in business he's soft i was interviewing
kobe
they laid kobe bryant when he brought up
shaq and the whole video and when he
said you know if shaq
would have practiced as hard as i would
we would've won 12 championships
it was all over the news everywhere you
know people were happy not happy all
this stuff shaq was not happy about it
i'm blocked by shaq till today by the
way
because of that what a dumb question to
ask you dm me and says what a dumb
question to ask
about if i had his work ethic right but
you know the biggest compliment kobe
gave shaq here's the biggest compliment
kobe give shaq
kobe said shaq was big and
mean he says shaq wasn't one of these
big guys that was soft he was big and
mean he says most
big guys you know people don't push them
around but shaq was
big mean and was willing to throw his
weight around
he wasn't soft he was tough right
big difference what do you how do you
define soft
soft as someone that doesn't have a
backbone as soft as someone when they're
cornered and push come to shove they
quit
soft is someone that claims their values
but then when it comes down to tough
things happen in their lives
they compromise their values soft is
somebody that
declares their intentions here's what
i'm going to do world
but then when it gets tough they say no
no no i'm going to quit and take the
easy way out
that's how you define soft you call
anybody anything but soft do you
understand like
how bad of a thing it is to be called
soft
but a lot of people are soft i have them
in my business
i've seen in my industry there were many
times in life
where in my mind i was about to choose
the soft
decision many times in my life this
whole ralph waldo emerson concept about
you know the only difference between a
hero and average person is the fact that
he can take the pain
five minutes longer that's the thing so
so if you're watching this right now
saying
how does that relate to me ask yourself
how do you react when tough times show
up
how do you react when you're getting
tested how do you react when you have
your pain
how do you do under pressure you how do
you do it and by the way
every single time you escape pressure
and you say well the next time it
happens
i'm not going to run no no no that's not
how this thing works
your memory remembers the last three
four times how you handle pressure
yeah let me say this one more time your
memory remembers how you reacted under
pressure the last three four times and
it just reacts to the same way you've
been doing
your entire life so if you say well this
didn't work out i'm gonna go to the next
thing
you're gonna do the same thing again and
again and again
and again because if you are willing to
persevere and those are the people we
read about
and talk about now a couple other things
here to be thinking about when it comes
down to this
um one night i come home
i've been i've been starting my company
for a few months already probably 11
months i come home
we're pregnant my wife's pregnant we're
expecting our first it's exciting times
and i come home my wife's in bed tears
crying
miscarriage if you're writing you've
heard me tell this story before
she had a miscarriage my checking
account is down to 13 000
that's not a lot of money when you run a
good company i have nothing else outside
of my 13 000
i go outside i'm walking around
i'm about to lose everything two
competitors came to my office that week
and they told me
how's it going to feel known when you
lose everything and all of these people
followed you
they failed because of you how's it
going to feel that was my nightmare by
the way
think about that how's it going to feel
knowing when everything goes down and
you file
bk and you lose everything and all these
people are scattered all over the place
you ruined their dreams because of the
decision you made
how's that going to feel huh how are you
going to and they're trying to
shake me one guy came into my office i'd
never forget this guy
came into my office and he told us to my
face and i
said who do you think you are i just got
into it with them
i said you want to come here tell us my
face on my turf on my property yeah
it's not an easy meeting that i had with
them i asked the guy to leave
and walk him out to the car told him off
you know what's funny nine years later
he called me and said can i work for
your insurance company
nine years later he brought his license
to me same guy that said i'm gonna go
out of business nine years later he came
to me
so what happens when you say i am not
moving or
shaking you're gonna have to kill me to
put me out of business
there's a certain mindset to that right
you're gonna have to kill me to put me
out of business
i don't know where this comes from that
walk that night i walked on i'm praying
saying i don't know am i doing something
wrong did i what am i doing what am i
doing that's offending you
if i'm doing something wrong then then
do whatever you got to do to put me out
of business but i'm going to fight it to
the very end
and the next you know next week i get a
check from aig for a hundred thousand
dollars
and everything turns and we go from
there this doesn't mean it ain't tough
times ain't going to show up again
this doesn't mean you're not going to
win some of these battles but it's not
going to happen because of me giving up
it's going to happen because i fully
went out of business for whatever
reasons
i'm going to do my fight to the very end
i ain't going to quit
i'm going to do my that's the mindset
pain alone there's
nobody i could talk to at that time i
can't talk to my dad because if i talk
to my daughter my dad said you chose to
start a business
i can't talk to my wife because it's
gonna give her more fear and another
miscarriage
i can't talk to my sister i can't talk
to my peers i can't talk to nobody
i can't talk to anybody in the company
about the anxiety and the pressures that
i have at that time
sometimes you got to do that as well
when you're going through the business
yourself so now
those are some of the ones that i talk
about let me add another one here that i
think it's important to
bring up in this session it's
overreaction how do you measure
toughness you know mental toughness
too often we overreact okay something
happens you have a follow-up with a
co-worker or an employee or a client or
this this
it's overreaction it's it's flight right
off the bat right it's
immediate flight right and
in those moments you have to ask
yourself your track record as i'm going
through all this stuff
i have a bunch of different notes i'm
probably not going to go through all
this stuff together with you
but i have a bunch of different notes
there's going to be some of these things
where you're going to sit there and say
that one relates to me right this one
relates to me
another element is being selfish
sometimes you just want to quit
because it's too much pressure for you
you know i have some talented guys i've
worked with over the years
and every time they quit or they stepped
aside for six months or three months
they made the selfish decision and they
would go about how it is good to be
selfish at times
but they hurt a lot of people every time
they did that why is that
because the decision was they didn't
want embarrassment so the immediate
thing was what flight
i understand that believe me i know what
it is to want a flight and not want to
take all the responsibility
because it's because of you that the
team is losing
you see this a lot in sports you see the
salon business
you see this a lot in a lot of different
places it sucks
pressure sucks being tested
sucks there's nothing about it when
you're in it
that's exciting nothing about it that's
exciting when you're in it
but there's a lot of great things about
it when you come out of it
there's a lot of exciting things about
it when you leave it and all of a sudden
you're looking at victories taking place
i can't describe that part too so now
when you're watching and say pat so how
do i how do i
how do i build these things for myself
we're having a conversation the other
day and i'm doing a conference call last
tuesday
a zoom and i said there is one thing
i'm not good with okay and i said what
is it
i said if there's ever one thing you
should never do with me
is one thing they said what and i asked
one of my uh
executives c-suite executive i said
marill can you tell everybody what that
one thing
is and i she doesn't even know i haven't
talked to her about it
she says never tell pat your goals
everybody's like why because if you tell
me your goals and what you want to do
i take it as you're serious about your
goals not me
i don't let me say that one more time
you tell me
pat i want to do xyz
then i say you're serious about it
absolutely positive yes
then i'm gonna hold you to that why'd
you tell me shouldn't have told me if
you weren't serious about it
but you told me i'm gonna hold you to it
now i'm holding you to it what are you
upset about you told me these were your
goals
why are you not going after it you said
these were your goals
well you know this is not that why did
you tell me these are your calls
i take your word because i believe your
word matters because i was raised by a
father that said keep your word
that's how i was raised so when you tell
me your goals
i'm assuming you're determined to make
those a reality so now you're watching
and saying what an annoying quality of a
person to work with
i understand believe me i'm not
disputing that i get it yes sure it's
probably an annoying quality to be
working with
but it is a quality that gets results so
moving forward
you want to build toughness you want to
be known somebody that
gets things done and you're not soft the
next time you're going to say you're
going to do something
do it the next time you're going to say
going to do something do it
the next time you're in a pressure type
situation where it sucks
and you have the ability to lose and be
embarrassed tolerate the pain a little
longer
go a little longer the next time you're
in a moment that you don't really like
being in
and it's embarrassing go a little longer
go a little longer
the next time you're going through
pressure type situations where you're
being tested
talk to yourself actually talk to
yourself and say
hey didn't ralph waldo emerson say the
difference between a hero and an average
person is that you go
five minutes longer i'm gonna go five
minutes longer how the hell did david
blaine go for 17 minutes and four
seconds underwater on oprah winfrey's
show and he thought his
you know her lungs are going to collapse
and his brain is going to be done how
did he do it
our body can handle a lot of pain that
we don't know about i'm going to push my
body to that level
i'm going to push it i'm going to push
it and test my limits that's the
beautiful part about life
let me test my limits and see what i got
going on and then you're going to
surprise yourself
so many times you're going to win every
single time but you're going to surprise
yourself
so many times while you go through this
having said that
having said that if this video was a
good video for you got another video i
want you to watch
how to make tough decisions if you've
never seen this video it's a video i
made about a year ago
click over here to watch it and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye